what should we start with man with the
mug shot with the mug shot oh that's
hard
you guys like that mug shot it's beaming
out fantastic I love it it seems like it
seems like the mug shot is is like the
nail in the coffin for every other
candidate now it's really become that
popular hasn't it they're turning him
into a political martyr it seems it's
true I think they're I think they're
gonna have to lock them up if they don't
want him to have any influence or win
like you it seems like almost
inevitable at this point that you know
he's got it in a bag with the popularity
growing isn't it
it was Elon Musk that said that if the
Democrats take uh Trump to prison
if there was him he's gonna win by a
landslide I don't know where the Tweet
is but he said that in very definite
words explicit
I think people are waking up to the BS
and this is just another symptom of a
much larger problem that everyone's
dealing with
who do you guys think is the best
candidate for for an American president
because I'm not convinced that Trump is
oh yeah
the best candidate or a disrupter I
think this end is on paper his
Brilliance is really good he's a great
executive but you want to go you if you
want someone to go in there with a
baseball bat and turnover tables and
wreck the whole place it's got to be
Trump
yeah he's like a bull in a china shop
obviously but I mean like as far as like
somebody that's that's better for the
country that can you know actually make
America great and turn things around and
potentially unify people you guys think
that it's uh how do you define that
because two different people might have
two different definitions of exactly the
same thing like how do you define
America make America great again like
what does that look like unifying it you
know I think that you know when you see
a country unified to a degree to any to
any degree Beyond where it is today
because it's completely segregated you
know at this point where it's like
there's mentally ill people and there's
people that aren't mentally ill and they
seem to be at each other's throats all
the time it seems like you know like the
Democrats want to Corral you know like
the weirdos and cater to the rainbows
and people kind of cutting off body
parts but there's like reasonable
Democrat candidates too like isn't uh
Kennedy a Democrat too like you guys are
gonna have to forgive me for being a
little bit you know dumb here because I
don't pay too much attention to American
politics you know beyond what you know I
see on Twitter but
what's the situation with that party
like isn't Kennedy one of their uh
candidates they won't run a good
candidate though I think in an ideal
situation which who knows if it'll
happen like a trump Kennedy ticket would
probably get a very large majority of
the vote but the Democrats will give
Kennedy the same treatment I think they
gave although I'm not necessarily a fan
of him uh Bernie Sanders like wildly
popular but yeah he's not really Towing
the line and then they'll they'll give
him the boot or they'll do some uh
some wonky stuff behind the scenes to
make sure he never makes it to that
level yeah so the Democrats set up a
thing called with super delegates okay
so if if somebody is a populist and is
winning then and they have these things
called super delegates which will get
their person that they want to get more
holes so they screw over burning again
it's you know it's a rigged system
yeah and the other thing is to charge
then is it the is it the
like these candidates these Senators the
like there's all these different layers
in
American politics I mean clearly the
president doesn't seem to be in charge
because if the president's in charge
then Joe Biden can be the President
right
yeah there's a whole there's a whole
like military industrial complex
learned about you know in that there's
the context itself so like you have
somebody like Trump who comes in and
disrupts it but they won't let him get
stuff done because they think they're
the ones in charge which is why you have
the FBI and investigating a sitting
president
right because behind the scenes they're
the ones that are kind of running
government like you can't just come in
and fire the entire government and hire
a new government like it doesn't quite
work that way so there's only so much
the president can do
what about dragons
the thing about Trump and doing the
swamp is that like
there's a swamp in New York and then
there's this swamp in Washington there's
a swamp in LA and or wherever though
right he knows he knew New York very
very well because he's going up there
he'd been a fixture there for 40 50 60
years going into Washington he didn't
know anything he would ask for people's
advice they would just lie to him and
then he couldn't really get things done
because he's he's kind of uh he's got an
Insider in Washington he doesn't have
that kind of political power amongst the
people that run things in Washington so
big black was that was a conspiracy
theory but just after what I've seen in
the last five years it's not and the
president doesn't run the governments
there's you know there's a cabal
keeps there and they decide what you can
get done and what you can't get done and
if they don't like you they'll use all
the Machinery the government
um look Peter thiel's company got
investigated Elon Musk is now getting
investigated by three different
government departments why because he's
sending Rockets to the Moon because he
makes amazing cars because you know he's
bringing thousands of jobs to Texas no
he's speaking out against the Deep state
that's why he's getting investigated
Raytheon I listen the big biggest
mistake it's hard to admit your
political mistakes biggest mistake I
ever made on the political right was
thinking corporations are pure and all
their all their far as profit no they're
not they're there for influence for
power for money and when corporations
get out of control and get into bed with
oh they got him they got him didn't the
left used to be anti-corporation I grew
up outside of Seattle Washington I
remember the 1999 WTO riots and pretty
much everyone shared that sentiment like
hey we don't want corporations running
our policy and then at some point in the
last 20 25 years they they switched all
of a sudden
I'm in Florida and I'm watching all
these watching all these fishing boats
going out it's just dead cam beautiful
weather here my full tell you what it's
what it's like it's just stunning and
and the Wi-Fi isn't a priority
so uh you were talking about the you
know about the cabal and corporations
and stuff like that and then you drop
can you you can continue on with that
idea yeah
as I said when people on the left used
to say that years ago
you'd be like operations or pures of new
drugs you know all they're interested in
is making a Prof it for their
shareholders no they're not they're
interested no in controlling dictating
why do you think you know they want to
crush Bitcoin they want to crush anybody
who speaks out they're
they're as bad as people on the left
always said they were you know that's a
mistake me and my peeps on the right
made was just thinking that corporations
are innocent profit driven entities well
they're not they're bad influential
people with money and power and
through human history when people get
power and money they do bad things for
us some of them do good but most of them
do bad stuff and they don't like the bad
management but if you want to see the
cabal go read the Time magazine article
that came out after the 2016 election
when they literally said we are the
cabal we are a coalition of business uh
scientists everybody and they said that
their main mission was to take down
Trump and they wrote an article six
months after the fact and published it
in Time Magazine
go go search for it so question for you
guys there's a there's a general sound
bite traveling around the manoswamp
about you know the election period where
it's like oh it's the election cycle so
they're going to start silencing voice
and voices that are red pilled or in the
mantle swamp and that was one of the uh
claims that I think um Myron made in his
announcement video on fresh and fit when
they got demonetized what do you guys
think of that
yeah like like the US government cares
about what Myron is talking about with
this one was from Miami well it's not
always six hoes sometimes it's eight
hoes or twelves sure sure but I mean
let's just
open mechanism I think if the government
doesn't really care about that it
doesn't really affect the elections like
I don't I don't see where the
correlation is
with that kind of show yeah and election
results like it doesn't make any sense
to me
I'd rather make the connection between a
certain white mask
resembling a conical type of figure
yeah isn't it interesting that they're
that they're starting the Rumblings
about Mass coming back and there was
that TSA announcement that Alex Jones
got a hold of that apparently ended up
being true that uh
it's you know starting to go around and
you know they
they tend to do this um or I mean they
did it last time where it's like you
know we'll have mail-in ballots and you
know if you're locked down a lot of us
can't go in you know it makes a lot
easier for them to
um I suppose manipulate the outcome
doesn't it
but not only that it also makes it a lot
easier for them to have an excuse to
pump money into the economy right
everybody's staying at home do some
stimulus let's print more money you know
like it's a emergency situation it makes
a lot of sense and if I look back for me
the the pandemic years were the best
three years out of the last six they're
going to run the same play they did in
2020 I believe why wouldn't they it
worked
all right you're gonna see what they can
get away with that's all it is let's see
how it's certainly holds so people still
yeah they'll push the line a little
further
I certainly hope so people there's
people that have a religious Farmer for
a government control they absolutely
love it I think it's the best thing ever
because their their policies they don't
their policies are so stupid that they
want the only way that people will take
their policies on board is if they get
the government to enforce them you know
play force a law and Ma you're down here
in Florida and when you mentioned we
mentioned masks to people last night
while we're out for dinner people have a
visceral reaction down here in Florida
that have been called off too
man I mean I was in New York so I was in
the epicenter of all of it and so I
remember not being able to go outside I
remember not being able to get on the
subway without a mask or GO train in the
gym or anything like that you could even
get into restaurants
uh without preventing some sort of fax
card or back scan and when I moved to
Florida and started having conversations
with people about this they were like
yeah like we were
quarantined for maybe a week or two and
we just went up to everybody's houses
and like barbecued and then it was over
and like that was it like they just they
didn't even live through it the way the
rest of the world did
that was the same in Southern California
too although it's a liberal state but in
SoCal when we got locked down it was
just massive parties on the beach house
parties like I've never seen before and
then they and then they put the kibosh
on that had the police patrolling the
beach but for me it was the weirdest
damn thing perfect weather year round
you're on the beach and I'm not another
soul in sight the cop car comes from
hundreds of yards away comes out to me
sir you need to be social distancing I'm
like dude I was social distancing what
what are you doing here you're the one
with the problem I was out here by
myself enjoying my morning but most
surprisingly most southern Californians
kind of took the same sentiments like we
we live Healthy Lifestyles we're not
we're not going to get sick and then
they they really brought down the hammer
on us
interesting I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out